christophe dupont bonjour merci d'être
avec nous avant d'évoquer cette
démission un petit peu surprenante deux
jours après le maintien assuré en pro a
je vous propose tout de suite un de
regarder votre parcours au sein du club
petit résumé de six ans passés à l'ulb
avec david joue ya onze années à l'ol b
christophe dupont incarner la continuité
l'image d'un club qui a de la suite dans
les idées
fin du cycle christophe dupont jette
l'épongé avec quelques mots lâchés dans
la presse saison compliqué je n'ai pas
senti de soutien de la part de la mairie
et surtout quand on a l'impression de
mener un bateau et que le gouvernail à
deux ou trois têtes c'est compliqué
fin de citation dans un club qui
s'appelait encore l'entente orléanaise
christophe dupont a connu l'accession en
pro a en 2006
assez vite orléans va tutoyer les
sommets avec un grand nom du basket à sa
tête philippe hervé autre symbole de
continuité
vice champion de france en 2009 quelques
matches d'euroligue et surtout une coupe
de france en 2010 le premier et à ce
jour unique titre majeur d'orléans dans
le basket français
c'est en 2010 l'entente devient le lb
supporters et partenaires se mobilisent
pour récolter des fonds manquants
suivront les années normales avec des
hauts des bas le départ de l'entraîneur
philippe hervé en 2014
et cette saison en cours crispante avec
un maintien tout juste acquis à deux
journées de la fin du championnat
conforté par l'arrivée de pierre vincent
à la tête de l'équipe un élément de
stabilité si son contrat est prolongé
christophe dupont va pouvoir redevenir
un simple supporters du basket à orléans
christophe dupont pourquoi avoir décidé
de démissionner bah écoutez je pense
qu'on était à la fin d'un cycle qui
avait nécessité de prendre un peu de
recul pour moi en fait par rapport à la
gestion du club
parce que la gestion on devenait un peu
plus compliqué que ce que j'avais pu
connaître ces derniers temps c'était une
année difficile voire paisible c'était
une année complexe cette année mais en
fait c'est une année que j'ai choisi de
ré pour lequel j'ai choisi de continuer
l'aventuré avec avec le club en début
d'année parce que je mettais déjà posé
la question de partir l'année dernière
et puis le fait de partir une donnée où
il y avait une transition importante
avec le départ de philippe n'était
certainement pas la meilleure des
formules on n'avait pas été toujours
soutenu dans vos choix de président mais
on est on est toujours parfois surtout
dans les années difficiles toujours
parfois remis en cause ou un complice
contesté sur certains points donc c'est
vrai que j'ai pas été toujours suivi
dans les choix que j'aurais souhaité
faire au moment où il devait être fait
question polémique elle cherche croire
le maire d'orléans et michelle martin
adjoint finances et il est membre du
conseil d'administration du club vous
ont-ils lâché un moment donné dans la
saison non non pas lâcher non non fin
décembre par exemple vous vouliez vous
séparer de françois perronnet on le sait
l'ancien coach mais le maire d'orléans a
préféré vous recruté le pivot à challes
mais c'est pas tout à fait ça mais il ya
eu une priorité qui a été menée au
niveau du choix de changement de pivot
qui était nécessaire qu'il fallait faire
ceci dit je pense que à ce moment là
j'avais présenté une option
supplémentaire et un choix important qui
était de dire on fait venir un autre
coach qui était pierre vincent qui est
accepté de le faire
quelques semaines après pour autant
retiendra de votre présidence le fait
d'avoir fait venir philippe hervé on l'a
vu dans le sujet et laurent sciarra et
cette victoire en coupe de france 2010
vice champion de france en 2009 c'est
beau souvenir c'est d'excellents
souvenirs c'est pas moi qui ai fait
venir philippe hervé c'est christophe
guérin qui était à ce moment président
que j'étais en fait on l'a vice
président d'eads
j'étais dans les coulisses mais c'est un
choix qui est directement à remettre
au passif de haut à l'actif de crise à
venir quid de l'avenir de pierre vincent
le coach actuel qui a permis à l'équipe
de se maintenir
là je me trompe pas c'est vous qui avait
fait venir réponse très rapide ah oui
tout à fait j'ai fait venir pierre et on
s'est engagée si on était maintenue en
proie de lui faire une proposition trois
ans ce qui va être fait très rapidement
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous ce
midi près